[Music]
it is May 7th and I've already played 25
new games this year
and aside from 2 or 3 of them they've
all been fantastic the last few months
one doubtedly go down as one of the
strongest openings to a year in the
mediums history but when I look back on
it and not just surprised by the general
quality of recent titles I'm also struck
by the sheer variety in one game I
fought my way through mythical Japanese
beasts in the next I hunted massive
robotic dinosaurs and yet another I
descended to earth with a squad of
androids clearing the way for the humans
we left back on the moon but just the
other day I started out last - it tells
a gory morbid supernatural tale about
fanatical cults in the American
Southwest it's tense and it's foreboding
at certain points it's downright
terrifying all in all it's a fairly
miserable experience yet I can't wait to
finish it this is always fascinating to
me why do I play games and I'm not
enjoying why do I spend time with games
that don't thrill me why do I pour hours
into entertainment that isn't fun in the
traditional sense I think we all do this
sometimes and I think recent games such
as outlast - a night in the woods
everything and what remains of Edith
Finch are important reminders for me and
for everyone that video games can be
much more than just fun
[Music]
so let's get something out of the way
right up front it's pretty tough to
define fun especially when it comes to
video games because we all play games
for different reasons maybe it's for a
sense of accomplishment
maybe it's an escape from our daily
routines or maybe it's for a sense of
community as we catch up with friends
and bond over our shared hobby but on a
basic fundamental level there's a
psychological concept that I want to use
it's called a flow State have you ever
played a game for what felt like 10
minutes but was really two hours have
you ever gone into autopilot when
fighting a really difficult boss you
were probably in a flow State it's that
fine line between excitement boredom and
anticipation and when you think back on
some of your favorite games chances are
they were good at placing you in this
state whether it's through fluid
mechanics well-placed gameplay or a good
balance between challenge and reward
developers often strive to encourage
this flow state if they do that they can
then build upon it with more complex
rules systems or storylines certain
games come to mind when talking about
this more traditional kind of fun Super
Mario 64 Super Smash Bros and the vast
majority of first-person shooters but
his games have evolved over the years
and creators have gotten better at
making them our definition of fun has
wavered and widened and this is a great
thing now I play games that are fun but
also games that can pull me out of my
comfort zone I play games that keep me
open-minded games that provides
something I can't find anywhere else
maybe this is why I love good horror
games with all their atmosphere and
psychological trauma they envelop me
more than any other genre they also
provide more agency than horror movies
which separate me from the events
unfolding in Halloween Michael Myers is
chasing other people in outlast -
deranged villagers are chasing me
think back on movies you've seen
throughout your life haven't you ever
finished watching a film and said that
was great but I felt awful the whole
time I felt this way about the revenant
the shining and Mulholland Drive they
led me through uncomfortable situations
they sometimes made me feel ill but
that's exactly what the filmmakers
wanted because there's value in that I
think games in their own way can
communicate stories and emotions we
might not otherwise feel we can
experience a situation in the shoes of
someone else someone broke in what they
wrecked the place through my typewriter
out the window we might not reach that
flow state that I mentioned that more
comforting sense of fun but that doesn't
make these games any less rewarding look
no further than that dragon cancer this
is a tragic powerful sometimes beautiful
story about parents doing their best to
raise a son with terminal cancer using
the interactivity of the medium that
dragon cancer shows young Joel Greene's
perilous journey through illness
recovery and his eventual death some
have said this game would function
better as a movie but that dragon
cancers creator Ryan Greene recognized
the value of agency inherent to video
games he could create a world for people
to not just see but also inhabit no
interactive spaces don't always have to
compel players to go on to the next
action or activity they they can help us
create a space where the player can
stand still and once the player is in
control of the pacing of the narrative
they can linger and then as the designer
we can acknowledge what they care about
and reward their presence
other games deliver negative emotions
without such a linear story take
something like XCOM to in its own way
this game makes use of much more than
traditional fun through turn-based
combat deep strategy and extreme
difficulty XCOM to conveys the pain of
failure as our favorite soldier dies
because of a simple mistake but it also
encourages us to roll with the punches
to make the best of failure and move
forward regardless then you have papers
please this game places you in the role
of immigrations officer in almost every
step of the way
confronts you with difficult moral
decisions you examine immigration papers
deciding who to let through who to
reject and in the case of falsified
information who to detain it gets even
more difficult when immigrants clearly
don't have the right papers yet they
have awful stories to tell about their
former homes
it would be easy to let them through out
of compassion but your salary is
contingent upon your performance and you
have your own family at home to feed as
well and this conversation would not be
complete without the puzzle game the
witness it is in no way fun
yes it's rewarding to the tenth degree
when you've spent hours trying to solve
a single puzzle only to discover the
solution right under your nose but I
would never call the witness fun and I
will never play it again yet it's one of
my favorite games in recent memory and
that's because the witness more than any
other game I can think of trust that
players are intelligent and it
communicates its ideas eloquently
helping you accrue knowledge as you
investigate this mysterious island and
it is knowledge itself that becomes your
key for getting around now don't get me
wrong I don't want every game to
communicate negative emotions or the
utility of failure or the importance of
learning one of my favorite games ever
timesplitters 2 is the epitome of fun
it's a shooter with goofy humor and
ham-fisted dialogue it uses time-travel
to justify having characters and weapons
from the Wild West the far future Soviet
Russia and 1930s Chicago there are evil
snowmen and undead priests I love it
with all of my heart
[Music]
yeah
but there are more intelligent people
making games by the day and many more
intelligent people playing them and
there will always be room for the next
zelda persona or Ghost Recon but that
doesn't mean we should discount games
such as a night in the woods everything
or what remains of Edith Finch simply
because they don't deliver fun in the
traditional sense personally I want the
medium to keep questioning and hopefully
defying what it means to be a video game
I want games to morph and twist and get
weirder and convey new ideas that fly in
the face of tradition I want developers
to be bolder with each new game they
create I want players to play these
games and to acknowledge that the medium
can be about much more than just fun
[Music]
hey everyone thanks so much for watching
episode 6 of reboot if you've been
watching this far then you know next
week Jake and I will be answering
questions about episode 6 and taking
suggestions for future episodes so in
the meantime your YouTube comments and
tweet at us Mike McCarty and Jake Decker
and maybe will feature your on show I'll
see you next week
you